côté de cela je suis foutu en l'air ma
mère
bonjour bonjour là bonjour
bonjour
au tpir
comme vous le savez je crois il ne va
pas revenir tout de suite et c'est sous
le tapis tu revends alors il m'a dit de
vous dire qu'il pense à vous
et qu'ils croient en vous voyant
[Musique]
et tous
continuer d'apprendre la vie ne soyez
pas sûr de vous essayer aux est risqué
tromper vous n'ayez jamais peur d'être
ridicule ne soyez pas prudent et bon
élève
c'était un désastre avec nous
la dernière fois que tu vas ce sourire
soyez généreux et authentique
avis et va continuer
cette confiance à votre jeunesse
et votre naïveté ayez des rêves et
suivez l'est
[Musique]
voilà
bah ya de la tendresse
n'ayez pas peur il est chaque chose
jusqu'au bout intensément
accomplissez vous
[Musique]